a capacity for existential flexibility
we stick with the Apple theme why not in
1979 Steve Jobs and a bunch of his
senior executives visited Xerox PARC in
1979 Apple was already a big company
they had already had the success in the
Apple one in the Apple two Steve Jobs
was already a famous CEO and as
executives do they visit each other's
companies and on this particular day
they went and visited Xeroxes R&D
division Xerox PARC in Palo Alto and
while they were there Xerox showed them
something they had invented called the
graphic user interface and the
grass-like user interface allowed
computer users to move a mouse so that
you could move a cursor over the desktop
and click on icons and folders in order
to work the computer in other words you
didn't have to learn a computer language
anymore as they're leaving Xerox jobs
says to his executives we have to invest
in this graphic user interface thing
remember if the cause is to empower
individuals to stand up to Big Brother
this graphic user interface thing
empowers way more people to be able to
use the technology the voice of reason
spoke up and said Steve we can't we
can't do that we've already invested
millions of dollars in countless
man-hours in a different strategic
direction if we change and invest in the
graphic user interface we're gonna blow
up our own company we can't just abandon
our investment to which jobs actually
said if we don't blow up our company
somebody else will that decision led to
the Macintosh a computer platform so
profound that the entire software of
Windows is basically designed to act
like a Macintosh a decision so profound
that it changed the way computing works
today that now a computer has become an
appliance inside our company inside our
homes and our companies for that matter
so common and we now live in a world in
which an individual can indeed compete
against a corporation existential
flexibility is the capacity to make
profound strategic shifts a hundred and
a degree
strategic shifts in order to better
advance your cause and failure to do so
may ultimately lead to the demise of
your own organization back when
blockbuster remember blockbuster was the
800-pound gorilla especially in the
United States basically you couldn't
rent videos from anywhere else except
from Blockbuster versus mom and pops
that were in the in your local
neighborhood and there's this little
upstart company called Netflix that had
a new business model based on
subscriptions that you would subscribe
you remember then they would send you
the DVDs and you can keep them for as
long as you want versus how we used to
rent videos in the past and the CEO of
Blockbuster went to his board and said
we have to look into the subscription
model thing especially where streaming
technology is getting better and better
we should probably prepare ourselves and
the board said absolutely not we may not
do that because we get 12% of our
revenues from late fees and we'd be
walking away from that revenue
blockbuster no longer exists and Netflix
dominates the industry because if you're
not willing to blow up your own company
the market will blow it up for you even
if it means making a short-term hit to
the short-term results in order to have
a capacity for existential flexibility
one you have to have a just cause B you
have to have trusting teams the cause is
what directs that flexibility this is
not like shiny object syndrome you know
that so many of us have either suffered
from or have been subjected to where
some entrepreneur get here as a speech
and here's the latest shiny object and
wants to redirect the whole company
there and you after the fourth or fifth
one this year everybody doesn't know
what the hell is going on that's not
what I'm talking about
I'm not talking about the daily
flexibility required to run your
business I'm talking about when you
discover a technology or a better
strategy or a better way to advance your
cause and you're willing to make the
straightest profound strategic shift in
order to advance your cause but you have
to know what your causes first and you
better have trusting teams because the
likelihood that you're gonna put your
company through upheaval in the short
term is high and your people have to be
willing to go along with it in other
words they say we agree this is gonna
hurt let's do it because if they don't
they'll all abandon ship
Kodak made the same mistake George
Eastman invented film George Eastman is
the
reason why you and I can take pictures
of our own families in our own holidays
prior to George Eastman the only way you
could take a picture was to hire a
professional photographer he was
obsessed with democratizing photography
he was obsessed with making it simpler
and simpler and simpler so more and more
people could engage in photography and
in 1975 one of the engineers Steve
Sasson at Kodak who believed in George
Eastman's just'cause invented the
digital camera unfortunately they've
been so many leadership changes at Kodak
over the years that the current
executives had adopted a finite mindset
and then they saw the digital camera
they decided to suppress the technology
for fear that it would cannibalize film
sales because the company had built its
monstrous monstrous self and based on
chemicals and developing and cameras and
all the rest of it and they couldn't
imagine the upheaval to become a digital
camera
they knew once the genie was out of the
bottle there was no putting it back they
knew they had about ten years the game
they predicted about ten years before
the digital technology would show up
somewhere else and amazingly to the year
exactly 10 years later digital
technology started to show up from other
companies and the digital revolution
started to take hold in fact Kodak made
billions of dollars from the royalties
they receive from the patents they had
for the digital cameras for the digital
technology and when those patents ran
out five years later they were bankrupt
because they refused they couldn't go
through the existential flex they had
abandoned their just cause they'd
adopted a finite mindset the teams were
no longer trusting teams because the
company was so driven by short-term
gains and short-term goals that for so
many years they thought they were doing
well because of those royalties until
they no longer existed as a threat or as
a significant market player do you have
a capacity for existential flexibility
if you want to stay in the game in the
infinite game you better
[Music]